when did you realize you were a
storyteller whoa
when did I realize I was a storyteller
probably in high school I think my
storytelling comes from two different
places so it comes from obviously family
and I come from a tradition of
trash-talking joke telling old Jewish
you know crazy like my grandpa my
grandma just seen around the table just
telling stories and so there's that side
of me and then the other side of me is
growing up in the 90s early 2000s like
around a lot of rappers and poets and
wannabe comedians and like you know I
grew up in DC and so like every white
Jewish boy of my generation I wanted to
be a rapper and quickly realized I
couldn't rap too good so then I got into
writing and poetry and storytelling and
from there it was kind of merging these
worlds and finding like everyone you got
to find your voice and just kind of
bringing it all together did you get any
pressure from family or peers to do
something else yeah I mean yeah my
family my mom still is like you make
money on this and I'm like well not
really but a little bit you know enough
to pay the bills so I used to I was
gonna be a teacher I was gonna be I
worked in schools for a long time with
different nonprofit organizations and so
I you know my my folks they you know
they you know they want you to have
health care and you know they want you
to you know be okay and pay the rent and
all those things and so far I've been
able to do that most months through my
art and but not they also for the most
part I'm black
that my parents and my family are mostly
pretty supportive and they understand
it's like you got to do what calls you
you got to do what makes sense and
mostly my mom's like I don't think your
stuff is very funny you but you know
nice try and better luck next time
so they're supportive not what I'm
saying is my mom's supportive in theory
but she's like well I don't think it's
that good but I'm glad other people like
it son keep doing what you do in some
ways you think that's almost helpful
because what if you had something where
was a pat on the back and everything you
do is amazing and then a while yeah no
my my family and my peers and my people
we don't have a lot of false praise and
it's good as a writer I need I need the
honest feedback and my wife oh she's the
toughest critic and that's what I'm like
like giving me to me Straight No Chaser
and then it's also good to have as a
writer and I have this with Yvonne in
the writers room it's also important to
have those times where you where I can
say I want to show you a draft and I
don't want all the feedback just yet I
just want to show it to you and like
don't like tear me down just yet just
like tell me you like three things is
there anything in here worth keeping and
like we'll go off that so I think it's
important to have both the like harsh
feedback but also the like safe spaces
I'm trying some new stuff out what do
you think so I get that definitely at
home and at work
do you not like to have yes people
around you I mean well you know I like
to have some people who you know our
support you know it's good like I said
you need both you got to have the people
who are supportive all the time who are
just like let's try it but I don't know
I don't really have yes people around me
so I'll let you know when
find those people when I get an
assistant and a manager and my agents
and and I have yes people I'll come back
and let you know I haven't I haven't got
there yet and I think that's okay
what's the most important part of the
writing process for you I don't know
what the most important part of the
writing process is but I know that the
the thing that I've learned over the
last couple of years that's been the
most helpful and the most for me why I
transitioned from more solo performance
and solo writing worked screenwriting
and being part of a writers room is for
me the writing is in it's not an
individual process actually it is for me
I tried to do the thing where you sit at
the desk by yourself and write a book
write the novel write the like bite and
that's just not me I couldn't do it and
so for me I write my first drafts with
people or I get the ideas talking with
people just just what do you think about
this and it's the writing happens
usually before I'm even writing the
writing is in conversation the writing
is trying stuff out trying ideas
questions I asked a lot of questions and
then and then the actual writing for me
is I was I'm still pen and paper I'm
still like I don't start on final draft
I don't start on the computer because I
just the internet kills me and even not
even the area just the screen there's
something about the pressure of the
screen and so I'm still if it takes
longer because I have to freaking
transcribe everything but I get better I
get sooner to the actually what I want
so I always start pen and paper and it
allows me to get free and really what it
does is it removes the editor in my head
while I'm writing if I'm on the screen
I'm like editing while I write if I'm
right just writing freehand I get a
little more that's usually where the
good [ __ ] comes out when you do usually
and you do something called why I write
right you stand up and do like open mic
different things and and yeah so I as a
writer I got my start as doing
performance poetry and spoken word and
then I moved I did a little bit of
stand-up and then I moved into live
storytelling in this Shana NPR called
snap judgment and so I did that for a
while and most of that is you know
autobiographical or semi
autobiographical or supposedly
autobiographical but at a certain point
I got to you know I have stories I'm I
can tell you stories about my life and
that's great and I love to do that but
there's other stories as a writer I want
to tell other than my own freaking life
and there's my whole community and my
neighbors and my friends and my family
and I want to do more than just me on a
microphone and so that's you know Yvonne
and I knew each other
just from Oakland and actually you know
we met playing soccer like this is like
we didn't start just working together we
were friends homies playing in a
socialist soccer club in Oakland called
left-wing Football Club and so like when
we just I don't even remember how we got
said oh I I just wanted to make some
videos it was you know early 2010 or
something it's like you know Internet
videos blogs vlogs all these things I
was like I want to do something you're
the you're the filmmaker and our crew
let's do something and I think some of
those still exist on YouTube they're
terrible they're freaking off I mean the
cinematography is amazing but I didn't
know what I was doing I didn't know how
to write for film but it's just
experimenting it's trying stuff out and
then little from little you know going
there to making larger
having slightly larger budgets and then
going from there to making the webseries
so why do you write why do I write well
you're asking the big questions I write
because I think otherwise I would go
crazy or crazier than I already am it's
a good crazy though yeah it's good crazy
mostly I mean writing is a beautiful and
also masochistic sport that like the
right like I love writing but it's it's
the let's talk about the good stuff the
the create I mean I write because I got
something to say I write because there
are things that I want to see that are
different in the world there's things
there's characters there's people that I
know and love whose stories deserve to
be told
whose aren't told in the mainstream
media or Hollywood or just even the
local press is like whose story is told
how is it told who are the heroes and
heroes who are the villains like I just
don't feel I just I want to complicate
the narrative I want to show a different
perspective and I also want to have some
fun and so for me
writing is the way to be both as serious
or as ridiculous as I am on a given day
and I want to show the breadth of who we
are as people and I want to show you
know there's a quote by one of my my
heroes Bertolt Brecht's old German
socialist playwright and poet and he
said art is not a mirror to hold up to
society but a hammer with which to shape
it and so for me writing filmmaking all
these things are way too not just
provoke people's ideas but to show a
different idea of what's possible and in
this country where we're so isolated or
so individually
we're so divided and put up against each
other and we're all the struggles of you
know American government political
corruption racism go down the list let's
use art to show something different and
not to ignore the pain but to name the
reality of this these are the problems
that are affecting people's daily lives
but what could it look like if it was
something a little different and so art
in writing is about that radical
imagination have you ever written
something whether it's performance or a
screenplay that it bothered someone and
they were very angry about it oh yeah
and how does that make you feel because
now you're feels like I'm doing my job
yeah the the one of the main criteria
one of the main signs of feedback that
I'm doing my job right is the level of
angry emails that I get if if I'm not
pissing someone off I'm not doing my job
as a writer if I'm not making you if I'm
not challenging you if I'm you know I
want my art to afflict the comfortable
and comfort the afflicted and so if
people in power are you know tapping me
on my back if I just have yes men as you
said just like oh that's good then I
could just be making commercials for
coca-cola but that's not what I want to
be doing so yeah there are times I'm a
I'm a Jewish writer who writes about
Israel and Palestine and sometimes that
can be a little controversial I'm a
white guy who talks about race and white
privilege yeah that sometimes people
have some feelings about that I work
with a multiracial team of writers in
Oakland even in the writers room we
challenge each other we sometimes we
don't we we're not sure if they're
saying what they want to say am i
speaking on behalf
someone else are you saying what is a
real representation or is that a
stereotype and so the first thing I feel
like is in the writers room is even
before the writers room and my
challenging myself and so if I'm not
challenged or if I'm not surprised or if
I'm not in a new place by the end of the
writing that I was at the start then I
haven't done my own job to myself and so
I feel like that's yeah you got a got a
and somewhere new has anyone ever said
can you tone it down and what is your
response to that you know that great
classic movie This Is Spinal Tap turn it
to 11 now we turn it up wait we don't
have time to tone it down
there's too much false politeness
there's too much trying to make everyone
it's not that I want to stir controversy
for the sake of controversy it's not I
don't you know I don't want just to
offend you or upset you for the sake of
a reaction the the idea is can we look
at some new perspectives the idea is no
matter where you stand we all know
there's some things that are you know
white between the rug not wipe wipe
dunder the rug there are some things
that are not talked about that needs to
get talked about and if art and film and
writing isn't the place then where is
the place to do that what takes you out
of a story and ruins it for you I think
that when you start to hear
a false voice like when and this is what
I have to guard myself against as a
writer myself is when you can hear the
character isn't sounding like the
character anymore but sounds like oh
this is the writer inserting what they
want you like just in case you didn't
know what I was trying to say when they
start to beat you over the head with it
with the message with the plot with it
you know our job is to show not tell
when when someone starts telling me
that's when I'm like you know the
curtain is revealed and I I get out of
this story and I'm like oh I see what
you're trying to do here and I don't
want to know what you're trying to do I
just want to feel it I just want to
experience it do you think voices are
silenced today as they were maybe back
in the 40s the storytelling is too scary
for certain people what do you mean by
that like whose voices artists now that
everybody has a camera everybody can be
the storyteller and put their ideas out
there you think it's scarier for the
powers that be if you're trying to
challenge trying to show people ya
something whether they're gonna agree
with you or not whether they're gonna be
angry at you I think it's a dangerous
time again I think is it a dangerous
time to be an artist and a storyteller
there's a more dangerous than the 40s
and 50s I mean my my grandmother was a
communist in the McCarthy era and her
friends were she was in jail for two
years I don't think it's a more
dangerous time for writers than the 40s
and 50s in the u.s. what I do think is
that there's more access because people
have means of production it's been a
little more democratized people can get
out their own stories people can have
their you know web series people can
have their blogs people can have but I
think the hard part
that hasn't changed is less about the
government suppression and censorship
and more it's about media distribution
and control and so I think we have way
more choices obviously we have Netflix
Amazon Hulu we there's a lot more shows
there's a lot more media there's social
media but I still think that in terms of
the main stories that get seen and
replayed and the big corporate
advertising that gets in I think we
still have such a limited range of of
stories of issues of narratives that is
widened up a little bit in the last five
10 15 years and I think you have to
credit especially black writers and
filmmakers who have really pushed that
open in Hollywood and Beyond and women
and queer writers and filmmakers who
have really busted the door open and I
don't I don't know if the doors busted
open I think it's like it's at least
cracked and now it's like let's get in
as many people as we can that haven't
been able to get in and so I think it's
opening but I think there is any time
you have progress you have pushback and
so we see that politically with our last
president - our current president about
progress and pushback but I think you
also any type of progress that we have
had in terms of media representation
storytelling politically and culturally
diverse perspectives I think is
important to know that and to be wary
especially with Republican governments
that repression can come quick and they
do come for the poets and the artists
and the filmmakers and the storytellers
like that is one of the first categories
on the list because you have to you you
want to shut down any dissent so for me
it's it's it's interesting we live in
interesting beautiful
absurd times did you meet your
grandmother you know her yeah my grandma
helped raise me she she was born she was
in these in LA her name was Dorothy
Healy and she lived in South Central
from the 30s until 1982 when she moved
to DC to help raise me and my brother
and so my grandma is my my hero and my
Shero my motivation and and she I just
watched a video clip of her actually and
she talked about she was joking she was
talking to some activists from the 60s
like some flower child you know hippie
generation up in Berkeley and she was
saying to them she was like you guys
think you have a counterculture we had a
counterculture we had music we had
writers we had you know we had Paul
Robeson we had you know Diego Rivera
murals we had like we had a culture the
culture and the politics were together
we had comedians we you know and so for
me it was interesting because we think
about the 60s as like the Renaissance of
cultural expression it's like
mythologized the 60s music and it's
beautiful but I think it was interesting
for me to watch my very serious
political activist grandma she
understood the importance of culture and
so for me as a filmmaker as a writer I'm
a cultural worker and you know it's in
the ascendant tradition when you started
writing the North Pole season one did
you see it as a movie or a web series we
saw it as a web series yeah we wrote it
knowing we would do these episodic you
know eight to ten minute episodes
because we knew this was a way we could
get it out this was a way that we could
have creative control but more
importantly you know we're mid-level
writers and filmmakers in Oakland we're
not you know we're not in the heart of
Hollywood industry knows knocking on our
doors five years ago we're trying to
break break in we're trying to get these
stories out there and so web series is a
way to start and so we started
episodically and we did the first season
and it did well enough that we were able
to do a second and so that's that's the
new one the season two that we're
excited to see and when we had our
premiere in Oakland and we it's on the
big screen I think it works and a lot of
people told us this could be a movie
like it works narrative Lee as a feature
and so for us that's a beautiful thing
because we want it to work each episode
can live on its own but also there is a
season arc that feels it feels like a
movie and so but for it yeah we started
as a web series did anyone tell you in
the beginning maybe you should tone it
down don't have it be so political or
did they say maybe you should turn up
the volume up the ante a little bit
honestly people did I don't think people
know knew what the [ __ ] to tell us when
we were starting I don't think people
knew what we were doing people were
excited and you know web series can mean
anything and everything under the Sun so
some people didn't know is this gonna be
like a short little thing and then we
were like no this is we want this to
have serious production value serious
writing content serious acting like we
want this this should be as good as
anything you've seen on Netflix because
these stories and these issues matter as
much as you know Gilmore Girls Season
nine or whatever so I mean I like
Gilmore Girls so that's you know that's
a compliment that's not this and I think
yeah I think for us we we both knew what
we were doing and didn't know what we
were
and it was that combination of
excitement and let's just make the road
by walking that's how we did it do you
think people outside of the Bay Area
will see magic and the characters will
connect with them I know the Bay Area is
very cos driven it's about the Bay Area
yeah gentrification other political
issues the show is about for friends
it's about for friends who live together
three grew up on the block one just
moved to the neighborhood it's about
like 30-something Millennials black
brown and white who are dealing with
their daily lives and also the larger
issues that are affecting them so I
think and we've done screenings of
across the country and we've done
screenings in Boston and New Orleans and
Detroit in LA and does everybody get
every inside joke no but there are
things that hit for everybody whether
it's the politics it's more it's about
the people and so our job is to make you
fall in love with these four characters
it's not I'm gonna hit you over the head
with these issues it's here for people
dealing with
I mean who how is a rent hike not
relatable how is your friend dealing
with legal issues not relatable how is
shitty bosses not relatable these are
all like these are human things these
are American things and for us that's
also where the humor comes in which is
we always start with the the comedy as a
way to kind of ease people in to the
story and and then once you're in you
think it's a nice silly comedy then we
drop a little bit of knowledge and go
from there you've crowdfunded for it
once or twice we did crowdfunding for
both seasons and yes so we did
Kickstarter campaign
and then the show is it's a unique type
of production it's produced by a
non-profit in Oakland called movement
generation that I work with and they
have invested and we have raised money
through different social issue grants
through filmmaking grants as a way to
cobble together the money to make a
production that we felt was strong
enough to to be worthy of the of the
people that we know and love and season
2 comes out season 2 comes out September
10th this Tuesday I don't know when
we're airing this but if you're want to
watch it the whole show is on the North
Pole show calm so it's on YouTube if you
google the North Pole but the easiest
ways the North Pole show calm its
executive produced by rosario Dawson
she's a cameo in this season boots Riley
who directed sorry to bother you is in
there and so we hope people watch it we
hope people enjoy it you know you get to
laugh you get to learn you get to talk
[ __ ] it's just you know it's a nice nice
hour of your time season 3 season 3 I'll
let you know
[Laughter]